Toss a coin to your new Witcher! If
you've been struggling to imagine
Liam Hemsworth as Geralt of Rivia, some
stunning new fan art is here to help.
When "The Witcher" premiered
on Netflix in late 2019,
fans of the popular novels and video
games were treated to largely faithful
storytelling and an accurate visual
representation of the source material.
The series tells the tale of Geralt, the
namesake Witcher, a lover of baths and
slayer of all manner of gnarly beasts. Although
some fans felt Season 1's multiple timelines
made it needlessly confusing, the show has
received generally good reviews for its CGI,
acting, and a second season that many fans
felt was a clear improvement over the first.
"Took me to the fourth verse to
understand there were different
timelines." "Oh did it? Wow." "And
that magic kiss? That was a bit cheap."
Season 3 of "The Witcher" has
been filmed, but with the news
that Henry Cavill is being recast with
Liam Hemsworth as Geralt for Season 4,
many fans are both displeased and
apprehensive about the show's future.
The English actor embodied the role
with the commanding presence, humor,
and charisma that he has become known for.
So it is only natural for viewers to feel
disappointment once the actor they are
familiar with exits a program. But with
some fan art already bringing Hemsworth to
life as Geralt, the future looks promising.
Digital artist royy_ledger shared an image
on his Instagram page that gives fans a
fun "preview" of what the Australian actor
could look like in the part. With Geralt's
signature yellow eyes and white hair and
beard, Hemsworth appears to fit the bill.
Hemsworth let fans know on
Instagram that he's pumped
to portray Geralt in Season 4
and beyond, posting, in part,
"As a Witcher fan I'm over the moon
about the opportunity to play Geralt
of Rivia. I'm truly excited to be
stepping into The Witcher world."
Despite his excitement, fan discourse is mixed
with much of the dismay stemming from Cavill's
leaving the part so many have become familiar
with through him. Over on Reddit, one fan posted,
"Well, at this point, after seeing Henry, who can
say anyone else will ever be right for this role?"
Another fan reaffirmed this sentiment by replying,
"Honestly, at this moment there's no actor on this
planet that is right for Geralt. (Except Cavill)."
Like his predecessor, Liam Hemsworth is no
stranger to action/adventure movie franchises.
"It is wonderful to see you again."
The Australian actor starred as Gale
Hawthorne in "The Hunger Games" franchise,
in addition to lead roles in "Independence
Day: Resurgence" and "The Duel." In his
Instagram post, Hemsworth shouted out Cavill,
acknowledging that he has big boots to fill:
"Henry Cavill has been an incredible Geralt,
and I'm honored that he's handing me the reins
and allowing me to take up the White Wolf's blades
for the next chapter of his adventure. Henry, I've
been a fan of yours for years and was inspired
by what you brought to this beloved character."
Meanwhile, Hemsworth received the
seal of approval from the "Man of
Steel" star himself. On Instagram, Cavill shared,
"In my stead, the fantastic Mr. Liam Hemsworth
will be taking up the mantle of the White Wolf."